previously on raft one singles here good
night
yeah what do you sleep you a-holes we
need to build it like a second floor we
need to stop going like out more up I'm
actually I'm gonna move all my stuff
upstairs I think that's the new plan
here we go god damnit get out of here
you scarecrow [ __ ] break some cheese
chopping away at the stupid decoy like
an idiot wait we have a clam I'm about
to solve our troubles seagull nest where
do you want it I use this whole top area
can you put it on one of the counters
down there where my god how do we fix
that nice little corner all right that's
nice I like that I like that land
something that way planned it this way
oh I see paddling paddling an entire
universe with one plastic shovel dude
woopsy for real tops it dirty is there a
way to get a permanent problem solving
to the shark or is that always just
gonna be an issue
it's always an issue but the metal spear
definitely deals more damage a thing
well this Islands tiny rabbits and stuff
under the water we need I didn't know we
were going for a bitch-ass Island yeah
well I mean [ __ ] ass island wade
pointed it out
maybe as good I may be maybe your eyes
are good
maybe you got good eyes to make one of
the better anchors now do we have that
we don't need a tracker oh we have it
but it costs a lot of things it's ten
planks six rope three ingots and one
hinge who would do that permanently so
it said just resources in the long run
oh maybe who is the chief they're all
liars why didn't I try this
you can cook shark meat on the little
grill you absolute scoundrels I didn't
say anything about it
I've never tried it you see monsters I'm
never getting you a present again if
you're gonna have that attitude about it
oh and I'm not ungrateful I'm just
saying we could have had so much more
delicious Sharkey gave you so much don't
appreciate it bit by bit
appreciate you bit by bit when I eat you
alive
sharks alive yeah I don't think anyone
thought the shark was not alive why was
that making do by the way it was why was
that making goo the water bottle and in
the something else the water bottle
alright a bottle I've got a bottle the
cooking part because we can get meals
we're gonna need I mean I made the water
bottle instead I'm an idiot
well I mean the water bottles good I'll
research the water bottle researched oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] binoculars oh [ __ ] not
oxygen bottle boom
oxygen bottle holy oh damn oh leather
belt anybody get that nice reference
tell me I'm nice reference tell me nice
reference button thank you that was told
her we talking about II need to kill the
shark he hurts some cool event yeah
may I have food some food dude gets in
there's so much food good why not there
you bastard get away get away get away
plug is it
this guy sucks I am good and I'm happy
to be playing but how late did you guys
want to go today I'm still wouldn't
we've been going oh my god we've been
playing this for two and a half hours it
turns out it's just real fun I mean
eventually I'll have to stop but oh good
place will we die that would be its
views I play rafts well we died in real
life that how about no all right so
schemer gets to you right to be that
good a video game it gets TOS to die on
stream yeah I'm pretty sure yeah that
sounds about right
go get my channel band yeah no no
Channel pants why are we getting our
Channel and what is happening on stream
absolutely all right once I get the
seaweed you're gonna get a cooking pot
Bob you're gonna get a cooking pot we
outta planks already is that possible
how are you getting going through so
many pranks I don't know I little one
stack of 20 like 10 minutes ago and just
use it to stoke my flames
I swear I've been putting down plank
after plank you go through a lot
whenever you're cooking all right at
some point here I'm gonna I'm gonna call
it good on the foots oh just you wait
until you get a cooking but my friend
well then I yeah do you want to make
some soups and whatnots unfortunately I
need planks to make an ax to cope I got
I got 20 you want some planks dude what
do you do next for well I need planks
actually I only need planks I'm almost
out of uncooked food right now oh just
you wait hey Bob I've got a present for
you a present for me have you had a
bruised rib I built a special platform
for it there you go you're gonna need it
mark I made oh my god oh my god oh my
god hang on hey
because oh wait I need one more plank
there's more plank down there there's
more plank and I'll get it plank on the
ground all right I got I got the I got
what I need I put this here I think I
need I think I need a post down god
so maybe the recipes you can post them
up on the board I don't how that way do
you need me to move this sale so you can
put one maybe in between these and if
you could do that well you totally
totally input the recipes up on the wall
that's adorable guys come look at my
recipes coming oh that's that's adorable
I love that that's so cool fish do I
need what is that bucket of it looks
like a bucket of geez maybe water I'm
not proud yes oh you know what it might
be might be milk we can actually on some
of the islands will eventually go to the
animals we can view to make the net we
can catch to them and share them and
milk them what oh goodness
is there an end game to this game that's
that's my question yeah there is an end
game or at least there's stuff added to
the end because eventually we want to
antennae like the radio receiver or
whatever and it'll kind of like guide us
somewhere and then apparently there's
even more to do after that now weird I
think we still have quite a lot of
content oh I I don't think we're
anywhere near the end just curious in
general we should kill this show all the
stuff we can get and get out of here
something get more wound you know we
always run out of wood I don't know why
it seems like we always have a plethora
of wooden and suddenly nothing alright
morning time for the shark to die okay I
guess we're doing this
why are we murdering a shark then we
need to get more stuff from the ground
dude
no it's coming back I keep thinking I'm
stabbing it but I don't see a puff of
blood so I'm not sure if it's actually
working well there is a little blood to
the laws to solid head yeah good bye
good bloods good blood man good July I
didn't get it nice nice coming back off
missed I got one Lumbergh
got it yeah more good armor my new who
we did good murder meat all right clay
quickly getting clay where's the goddamn
grab metal rap metal grab everything you
can find other than stone I think
anymore stone but yeah we have plenty of
stone all right back oh harvest ins more
man how are we still plank for what is
this
I don't know need to get blanks when you
get like six of those large crop
planters just have tons of trees planted
I think yeah I can do a little tree farm
expansion up here whoa it was a crate
down here it had wood in it weirdly
enough not great for good for us right
now yeah I'm like straight out of planks
that can no longer cook things no I know
oh that's where our planks go I was
wondering how they were being consumed
it's fine use that many I use like I'm
not blaming you I'm just saying I was
just curious of where they was all going
I didn't know I use a lot of planes I
know I know I know I know I know you yes
it's true I do
oh hi wait youyou didn't go like a
different direction around the island
you what the same one you went the same
way following the trail of unharvested
metal ore and scrap metal uh-huh you
keep telling self that you keep telling
yourself the clips will tell the truth I
don't see for you you really are I'm
just mumbling to myself I don't even
care you'll need to know what my
character is now you're kind of ego my
character is it pronounced I Gor of
course yes tell me this this log on the
ground isn't something gather Bowl let's
do what do you people have an axe yeah I
make an axe oh yeah I think I'm tree
ready to harvest I'll come get it
no actually Bob I got another present
for you all prezi's
here
yeah uh uh X I think we got everything
in the island I'm pretty sure we've okay
we can we can land ho whoa I just
sneezed so hard that my butt hurts is
that good yeah perfectly natural
occurrence actually it's concerning to
me but as long as do you guys think it's
okay then I believe you it is okay we're
getting back calm down i Gor you think
you know I Gor what I gonna ask you
something
may ask you something no think that's
funny but it's not
it was those no money no that's real
funny sir guys I'm gonna make a potato
beats to okay I don't know what I'm
doing but I just put two beats and two
potatoes into a stew and I'm freakin
doing it I'm God dang doing it hacking
Frick you know me freaking freaking heck
in for a guy you thinking you know that
I know you I know you know me back the
plastic can we melt plastic and just
create some fumes and hail them and
didn't die that's exactly what I was
thinking raft that way I'm aiming the
thing to the thing of it that way Oh
god bless you Bob and your food infinite
supply of food you're welcome god bless
you Bob
look at the cooking pot is doing Chunkin
away what you making I'm making potato
beats to it turns out you could just put
any four things in here you want tell it
to start cooking and it makes something
okay it'll give you it'll be like shits
do if it's not the recipe I bet it ain't
no indeed go really well together okay
so for that achievement complete a more
complex concoction oh well done wait how
do I get it out of here do we need a
bowl or something to get it out of here
yeah clay Bowl I've got one
way no you need to clay it looks like
potato and beets to guys it looks
delicious is it I don't know because I
can't eat it apparently unless I
specifically have a clay Bowl there's no
other way to eat this stuff oh we got a
bolt and a recipe for wrist simple fish
stew again ok whoa is that are you
seeing what I'm seeing big island I said
I see big island
oh my god dude we just hit island
bonanza oh I don't see it but I believe
you do you one my eyes are so tuned into
this game do you have those binoculars
no way baby these are all natural that's
it no now you do so we don't have any
more player right here Bob this is all I
got
clay I need literally two if we have any
we got one more here oh sure keep going
jerky I come on amazed I can do that I'm
gonna make me some clay bowls and see
what the deal is with this stuff sounds
good sounds good sounds like vegetable
soup dudes
look at my steaming vegetable soup Wow -
hey you know I am hungry how can you say
you need some steaks um I'm gonna throw
it on your feet apparently they go
perfect tell me how much that fills you
up dude let's see oh it gives me a
little green bonus on the top of my
health bar Oh bro guess who's making all
the vegetable soup from now on oh my god
that fish was useful the fish like a gun
give me everything in the register I'm
bout to anchor anchoring oh I think
you're doing anchored Oh God it's not
something we can grab that's unfortunate
I know that really does look like it now
we're kind of on the wrong end of the
island but whatever oh I remember what I
was gonna make a long time ago
gonna make flippers you four flips Oh
but ladies and gentlemen we're about to
have two smelters what right foot bite
right below me there's like a cave under
the water we need to breathe there's or
something
oh I've not moved in so long my ass your
ass your ass part of it hey you got one
plank you can spare Bob I am no planks
way down those trees get you one you
need a plank bro I got you bro I got you
oh my god Bob no it's fine it's fine
it's worth it you need this plank bro
thank you bro here's your one plank bro
totally worth it bro I can't pick it up
why is this low bro have you bro I can't
pick it bro that thing with the chomping
on my stuff oh god I got a guy is the
bird it was the bird who's the bird okay
we're fine fine double smelter baby
doubles mil back dual smelter you got
some planks thank you thank you dude
we're so food rich right now I'm gonna
stop making food forever
yeah dude take a break you you've done
enough
you've got a dog should I brave the
ocean try to kill this bad boy I'll come
with you
where we going my spirit I guess it's
almost dead actually we have anything to
make another sphere perchance we need
planes for that but we don't know bro
okay well if we get some planks I got
the rope with me I'll just crash one on
the fly to work mark you lead the way
let's go murder this a-hole is murder
they own
oh hey old murder I'm gonna stab it
right up as a whole how do we get up
this island just spam oh you write you
write also a Bob you have an axe right
you've axe yeah yeah hey there's a crate
up high there's a crate hey that's a
crate over there I was jumping down here
on purpose to chop down this tree is
there fall damage
oh god I'm on the way oh no oh we got
wood Oh did actually get what I want
okay I think cuz our scarecrow has
escaped stupid idiot those are the
useless ones come back Oh miss look he
attacked our protective defensive ones
like a [ __ ] my spear broke I wish I had
a spear I wish I had a spear I can make
you a spear bro you want a spear rope
yeah sure spear bro I can't make you a
metal one but I can make you a void
server I'll take a wood Spears wood
Spears go come get your wood spear bro
thanks bro
we could make a bow and arrow I can't
pick I can't pick it up I can't god I'm
gonna go get more stuff and kill a shark
haha damn it haha oh he hurts so bad he
really hurts he's kind of a a-hole
he is she is a hole
oh you're right oh there is kind of like
an underwater cave here I am gonna die
oh no that's so scary
Wow
okay one more hit and I'm down I got I
can take one yeah we got a stoop up here
boyo I will that help my Healey I don't
know you some kind of bonus or something
alright if I put this vegetable soup
recipe on your does it just like oh
they're real oh is that literally the
recipe that I just guessed yeah you
randomly you you did it man
dude you did i hack and did it bro what
did it boom damn well soup up in this
piece damn we need to get a big-ass wood
situation going on here yeah woods for
some reason whoa shark killer get out of
here you dick weed okay
dammit how strong is this one this one
seems to be extra strong you guys want
to get on the road or yeah what's
getting out of here alright
oh it's your raft I think towards the
barrel to the right you're pulling me in
two different directions here I can only
go so many ways yeah barrel first Noddy
now for the other raft is there any
other monster besides the shark that's
gonna come out after us if there is it's
not until we get further than I've
gotten which I've really only gotten
through the base game mostly so it's
highly possible wait fine bye bye guys
alright he's fine he's fine
don't worry about him leave that seagull
alone that's a good seagull give us
babies oh is it over there oh so cute
should we do a perpendicular side with
um Nets so that no matter which
direction we're moving we're always
catching some stuff yeah it seems like
the raft now wants to go that way so we
could move all the Nets to that side
since it seems like we're dragging in
from that side right now it's because
the sails facing that way well the winds
pushing that way so you know checkmate
sails facing that way which way your
sails face it's not the other way that
doesn't make sense how why would why
would the wind obey what my sail is
doing what will higher with mark alright
hey I'm moving I'm moving the nets I'm
doing that because I think that's in
play I think that's play yet multiple
sides how about you shut up the only
problem is gonna put it by that bird
wait wait the bird is doing things give
it a second it's doing stuff maybe it's
done what if I sneak yeah good thing you
put all those points into stealth and
dexterity yep
alright seems good wait a minute I
dropped something into the ocean and it
sank forever no no it's floating it's
loading its loading loading ok it's
loading I'm fine I'm fine
apparently queue drops your things I
dropped I threw my hook into the ocean
it's a shark and anger that's a bad pun
depressed
yeah yeah yeah man you should control
yourself that is pick it up can I get an
assistance on this that's an annoying
thing I think it's because the stupid
server that stupid Wade is hosting is
being stupid
by the way wait from oh my god the
number it was you were not kidding about
potatoes what about potatoes potatoes
that we have yeah yeah I should have
been cooking those I should have been
saving those [ __ ] for vegetable soup
yeah oh no Bob you just scared away the
bird I don't even have a way to cook an
egg so I'm gonna move the nest over to
this kind of underside beneath the thing
cuz we don't go over here so this should
be fine
you know you nah mean architects it's ok
sharks come and go but love never
changes I'm gonna enjoy your delicious
soup here Bob all for you baby goodness
that doesn't give any thirst it's such a
thick soup you know you just gets in
your teeth and you can't really get any
yeah no that's good stuff who's these
noobs who can't hit [ __ ] with their
hooks wait and i just crisscross like a
couple of idiots look it's been a while
since we've done some hooking you know
does anyone need Oh does anyone need
something that requires metal because
we've got a surplus of metal new hooks
in so I'll need one bolt so I'm wanting
it changes for tree plots if we want to
do those alright alright ok wait in the
in this in this eating with the flowers
I'm going to put one two of three ingots
for cooking I will put one two sorry and
I will take a bowl of soup as payment no
have you been stick dude I'm just
cranking out the soups right now boom
BAM soups up in here this is good stuff
like it makes me think that this wasn't
like a horrible accident where we added
you like a capsized ship or something I
think this was a voluntary and coming
never mind oh this we chose this life
because this is a life for us
cover your [ __ ] is how is it alive
how don't mock me who I actually am
curious I've won oh I wonder I'm I'm
very curious I'm about to do something
bold Kabul you're about to see double
sail be are we about to start I don't
know if two sails means twice the speed
and I don't know physically the where
they're placed is gonna mess up but two
sails you know we got two two trees
growing now oh I think we actually are
busting it leg twice the sail speed
we're just falling all in serious ass
right now dude there I've never seen
bigger asses being hauled than what
we're hauling right now well now I got
this extra space over here I don't even
know what to do with I got space I got
plots it is really nice up here right
this is this is where your food comes
from my boys Wow self-sustainable
whoa-oh-oh bro bowls of soup stack well
Big Island do straight left
oh hell yeah honk Big Island sail
turning trim trim them do them Tom these
sails are so fast the barrel sucks go
for they perfect time I'm gonna build a
anchor real quick okay then we're gonna
I'm gonna go get some more underground
ease may those sails
yeah these sails were no joke okay hurry
up get out there oh yes baby give me the
clay I want another one another furnace
oh this is thick with clay a scrap metal
would be good too
I got scrap metal to do hey what do you
guys have been eating the soup do the
bowls disappear maybe I've eaten a soup
yet I've had soup I don't have bowls
really they go away you like Thor style
slammed
on the ground some good soup oh my god
this is the island of clay oh [ __ ] I'm
about to die oh god I'm so far
underwater Marc I shouldn't have fired
going back down that's a kid oh [ __ ]
that is a cave it looks like it oh I've
got enough clay for another furnace by
myself oh my god I love this look at
this man's okay as soon as the Sharks
back though I'm out of here
did you go in the cave no did you yes no
you're on your own in there character
can put it away
I just a like nine whole potatoes
I lied there's a crate here and I think
diggable soil may be all right I need to
take a quick quick a break boys don't
worry I'll guard the raft okay you got
okay I'm pretty much full up on stuff
I'm gonna come back soon what is this
why does this little tiny dick water no
no I'm out of water I'm going very slow
hang on okay this is bad okay fine okay
can you get some goo can you get some
seaweed and while you're out and down
there oh I can try I need some water I'm
kind of feeling sharks maybe back like
any second sixth sense that he might be
around laughs I know what makes you
think that what could possibly make you
think such a crazy weight intuition
Wade's intuition doesn't sound very
reliable
I trust it the only equation I've ever
had that demon chuck some things out and
can't pick them up yeah what is this bug
where I can't pick up items I don't see
any vines over here hey when you get
back to the the thing can you hear me
are you ignoring me I hear you you told
me look for vines I didn't see any fine
oh okay there man did you see any vines
in their back no I found a lot of clay
though there's a shirt guy sits back
it's just me hey can you come up here
and grab this um
these two bricks off the ground put them
in this box
thanks they're still wet I know do you
have any clay for clay Oh hand me that
you only have four clay
oh I can't don't hand me that put it in
the box thank you dude
I can make two more furnaces can you
chop down the trees on that one too you
know I don't have an axe anymore I guess
I could make an axe
well I'm in an act so I'm gonna go chop
will you have to sharpen job and good
you're dropping shut the ground is your
favorite oh yeah very full yeah yeah
what's up my recommend not oh you'd open
the coconuts don't do that I did anyway
what are you gonna do about it be sad I
did not expect this game to be this fun
you've even gotten to the new stuff this
is like the what we've not even the new
stuff the animals that you can like
start raising and milking and shaving
another cool [ __ ] oh oh dude Bob just
zip around for years whoa yeah the OL
ocean just zipped around for me am i
back yeah I think hello the whole ocean
just had a whole spasm oh wow well
you're gonna love this we are about to
have four furnaces my dude sick yeah if
you need metal you ask me we we are rich
with metal with same as we're rich with
food we are rich with metal rich with
metal and soup oh my god we're gonna
have so much metal and so much soup so
how many more days are we playing this
game until we die is that the plan
[ __ ] loving this this is so much more
fun than I remember this game being by
such a wide margin so I'm playing with
people alone this would be stressful and
just non-stop grindy oh god yeah that's
what I experienced when I played this I
was just like oh my god when is it gonna
end
oh we learn more stuff battery 30 holy I
do not think we can make a circuit board
I'm just like statement I don't think so
are we good do uh we good to go I think
so I didn't I don't know if I fully
searched the underwater of the island
but I think we're good all right I'm
gonna place my other smooth yeah just
those four and then we're good we can we
can go ready go Bob
yeah I pick up that anchor smelters are
good oh yeah oh my god I'm so happy
damn uh actually that's four o'clock I
want to keep going but I need to get
some food and then gear for another
recording session I mean yeah that's
okay
[Music]